hello i'm going to talk about a
generalized
matching reconfiguration problem and
this is joint work with norm solomon
the maximum matching problem is a
fundamental combinatorial optimization
problem and we can consider either
the unweighted version where we would
like to compute
a maximum cardinality matching or mcm
or the weighted version where we would
like to compute the maximum weight
matching
or nwm this
problem has been extensively studied
over the years
in a variety of settings
but we are going to consider it from a
perspective of
re-optimization or reconfiguration
let me try to explain what i mean by
that
so we have now a graph a network g and
some
matching m for g
so let's assume that we are in the
unweighted case
so m is some approximately
optimal mcm 4g let's say 1.1
approximation
and you can imagine that m is being used
for some
practical purpose such as scheduling and
in particular the edges of this matching
are giving service to some application
and now we are given access to
a better matching game prime a larger
matching in this
case maybe we are the ones
who computed this matching in the
background or maybe we are given access
to it by
a third party and
the blue edges in this illustration are
the edges of
m the black edges are the edges of m
prime
the larger matching and we are going to
call
m the source matching and m prime the
target matching
and the premise is that we are now going
to go
from m to m prime
so the first question that you might ask
is why
did we start from small matching
there could be several reasons one of
them is that maybe
we have limited resources maybe
the the matching is not
computed by us maybe we receive it from
a third party
and another reason might be that um
the the matching m might have been
really great maybe even
the maximum matching for the graph but
it was a while back
and the network g has changed in the
meanwhile
either by temporary failures like
communication links that crash
or by permanent changes that are part of
the normal behavior
of the network one way or the other
the matching that we have for the
current graph
is not good enough and we would like to
switch to a better matching
okay so we are going to use here
a gradual transformation process
so we are only gradually going to move
from
m to m prime we are allowed to make just
a single edge change per step
to the output matching
starting at m and eventually coinciding
with m prime
and we we also uh
require that the intermediate
configurations along this process will
be
matching and also large ones but we will
get to this
in a second okay so why
should we employ a gradual
transformation process why can't we
transform from m to n prime
instantaneously
so here first of all this network could
be
very big and it might be prohibitively
expensive
to carry out such a transformation
instantaneously
in fact it could be even infeasible to
do this at once
and here you can imagine that the
edges of m that are giving service
to some application are hardwired in
some physical sense
okay so we are going to apply a gradual
transformation process that could be
slow
okay so what we would like to do is just
um
abandon all the blue edges and move
instantaneously to the black edges and
then
designate them as the blue edges sort of
speak
so that now they are the ones to give
the service
but this is not what's going to happen
right so
and this also explains why why do we
need
to have large matchings throughout this
process
because we would like to continue the
service throughout this possibly very
slow transformation
and we are continuing this service with
the edges of the output matching
that gradually changes so if that
output matching is always guaranteed to
be large
large with respect to the sizes of the
source and the target matchings
then the services that this matching
will provide will be
uh reasonably good and you say that the
size lower bound that we will try to
enforce
is smaller by one unit
than the sizes of either m or m prime
we we could assume that the size of m
prime is no smaller than the size of m
but one can also imagine situations
where
we are going to switch to a worse way
to smaller matching due to some
practical considerations okay so we are
allowing this
unit of decay
unit of slack and
okay so now why why should we allow this
unit of
slack consider two
black edges we would like to
move them to the output matching but we
cannot do this
because they are incident on this blue
edge that is currently in the output
matching
so in order to add one of these black
edges we first need to
delete this blue edge
so we are starting off by
this unit of loss to the size of the
matching
and in fact any black edge that you
would like to add to the output matching
in this example
will trigger this loss
okay so we have to have this unit of
loss and
and you know once we've deleted this
blue edge
we can designate this black edge
uh as an output matching edge and later
we can designate this one
okay so by coloring the edges blue i
mean that these edges go
to the output matching and
you know let's say that i would like to
put this edge in the
output matching to this end i first need
to delete the blue edge incident on it
and so this is what we are going to do
we are going to
uh employ this gradual transformation
process
until all the edges of m prime
become the output
matching edges
but you see that even this one unit of
loss is not
always sufficient
okay so let's say that the
two blue edges are the edges of the
source matching and we would like to
move to the two black edges
but adding even one of the black edges
requires us first to delete the two blue
edges
from the output matching okay so this
encodes two units of loss okay so
sometimes we need two units of loss
to the size of the output matching but
we never need more than two
units of loss okay so
in the previous work by etheretal
they studied the
the complexity of several
reconfiguration problems including
the matching reconfiguration problem and
they gave a polynomial time algorithm
for this decision problem of whether or
not
there exists a gradual transformation as
we discussed
well you never decrease
the size of the output matching by more
than one unit
again it's not always possible so the
answer should be either yes
or no if it's possible or not and their
argument
i would say is non-trivial and it is
in particular based on the edmontology
decomposition
and they also conjectured
that one can get a similar result for
weighted matchings
in the same paper they studied
some other problems so for the minimum
spanning tree
problem and more generally from for
metroid
problems they gave the polynomial time
algorithm
and they also showed that
quite naturally the reconfiguration
versions
of various np complete problems
is p space complete and they considered
problems like
maximum independence set minimum
vertical and more
but it's not always the case that
the reconfiguration version of any
np-complete problem
is v-space complete
and it's interesting it's an interesting
direction to
explore this question more deeply
because currently it's not fully
understood
now there is a large body of work
on graph reconfiguration problems
and the setup is rather general
so you can imagine that we consider a
configuration graph
for some search problem such as maximum
edging
and the vertices of the configurations
correspond to feasible solutions of this
search problem
and the edges correspond to adjacency
relation on the set of configurations
so there are some details that i don't
want to
get into such as that this adjacency
relation
ought to be polynomial time testable
um but there are
um quite a few questions that we can ask
so the first one could be is there a
path between two given configurations
which is the analog of whether or not
there is
a gradual transformation process between
these
configurations we can also restrict
this path to being of a certain length
and we can also pose other restrictions
on the
vertices that belong to this path
we can also ask more global questions
such as
is this configuration graph connected
maybe the diameter is bounded by some
threshold and so on
and a part
or maybe even a big part of this line of
work
is motivated by practical applications
such as to motion planning so here for
example you can
consider a set of robots that would like
to
move along edges of the graph and
obstacles could be
located at some vertices in the graph so
on
reconfiguration problems could also
model evolution
and this has been done in
ontology evolution biology evolution and
it's
very intimately related to questions in
computational genomics and gene editing
in particular
there are applications to markov chains
and another i would say
practical applications broadly speaking
but also from a more theoretical
perspective most of the combinatorial
games and puzzles that you can think of
can be cast naturally as reconfiguration
problems
now if you think of a configuration
as a set of elements which is some which
is something that you can
almost always do
then typically a pair of configurations
is adjacent is defined to be adjacent if
they're symmetric difference is
precisely one
and of course this is very restrictive
um the it's not always the case but
i would say that in
essentially every work that i'm familiar
with
the idea is to pose restrictions on the
adjacency relation so that we'll get a
decision
problem whether or not for example there
is a path between two given
configurations
and so on now what we are proposing
is quite different we would like to
relax
the problem by introducing an additional
parameter delta
that controls the symmetric difference
size between
adjacent configurations
and we notice that when delta is equal
to 3
there is a simple linear time
gradual transformation process and
specifically
take any graph g any source and target
matchings there's always the gradual
transformation process from
m to n prime well you're allowed to make
three at most three
edge changes to the output matching
well the matching size
never goes below this
threshold so we still have this 1 this
is inevitable
the running time of this transformation
is
linear in the sizes of the matchings and
if you think about it
this is optimal with respect to all the
parameters
you cannot reduce delta from three to
two unless you are willing to
include two units of loss
you can think of the full cycle and you
cannot hope to
uh you cannot hope to reduce this minus
one to to shape this minus one
and then two you can think of the full
cycle and of course you can increase
delta but then i can
use as a counter example a longer cycle
now this is a simple theorem to prove it
is more challenging to generalize it for
weighted matchings
so here we don't want to
go down below the weights of the source
and target matchings by more than w
units well w is the maximum edge weight
and we can massage this parameter to get
something that is
closer to the average weight or at least
not maximum edge weight in the entire
graph
and the running time is as before it's
linear in the sizes of the matchings
and more interestingly perhaps
if we are increasing the symmetric
difference size
delta one over epsilon then we can make
sure that the weight
of the output machine never
goes down by more than a factor of one
minus epsilon
and this is uh i believe more
interesting
and so in general we can get the maximum
of the two
whatever is better
and here too in general
what we get here is optimal with respect
to all the parameters
now we'll see an application of this
gradual transformation theorems to the
area of dynamic matching algorithms
so first a quick recap on dynamic
matching algorithms
let's assume for simplicity that we have
n
fixed vertices but the edges come and go
now at every update step a single edge
is either inserted or deleted
and let's assume that we start from an
empty headset
now following every update step the
algorithm
has to update the matching of interest
and for concreteness let's assume that
this is a maximal matching
and therefore also a two approximate mcm
okay and we see a very naive
algorithm for maintaining a maximum
matching very briefly
so the first edge
comes and the algorithm
adds it to the matching there's no other
option the blue edges are the matched
ones
then the second edge comes and the
algorithm
doesn't have to do anything this is
already a maximum matching
the third edge comes the algorithm
adds it to the matching and so on and so
forth
and and it's not like we
have only insertions
here is an example for a deletion of a
matched edge
and then the algorithm can cope with
this deletion by
adding this edge to the matching in its
place
and the most basic goal of
an algorithm in this context is to
achieve
a small update time
okay so the update time of an algorithm
is the time it takes the algorithm to
update
the the matching
following a single update step and we
can either try to optimize the amortized
uh bound or the worst case bound
and there are a bunch of dynamic
matching algorithms with
very small update time bounds even in
the worst case
okay so
it's not like this area is fully
uh resolved there are um
many open questions but i just want to
mention that there are um
a lot of non-trivial algorithms with
very low update time bounds also in the
worst case
whereas for the recourse bound which is
another
interesting and important quality
measure
very little is known and
so the recourse bound measures the
number of changes to the
output matching per
update step and in the nave algorithm
that we saw
we made just one change to the output
matching
but it doesn't have to be this way maybe
following a single update step we change
the matching completely yet
the update time could still be very low
because maybe we are just changing
pointers from one matching to another
it could be a constant time operation
but the recourse bound could be huge and
so
although the update time of an algorithm
is low sometimes we would like
and and this this is important sometimes
we also need
the recourse bound to be low because
maybe this matching algorithm is
embedded inside a bigger data structure
or algorithm and a high recourse bound
will trigger
significant blow-ups to the bigger data
structure or algorithm
and controlling the correspond
is also important for other reasons and
you can take
a look at the paper for more uh
reasons that's great so we would like to
control the recourse bound
and perhaps surprisingly almost all
known dynamic matching algorithms
that have a low update time in cool
a high and very high worst case for
correspond
and sometimes these algorithms call
a high amortized recourse bond
okay so to remedy this we propose
uh the following theorem which can be
viewed as a black box reduction
and i'm starting with the unweighted
case
so let's fix uh
an arbitrary beta parameter beta at
least one
epsilon greater than zero and let t be
some
uh runtime function
and n is the number of vertices in the
graph
so what this theorem says is that if we
have
as input
any dynamic algorithm a
for maintaining a better approximate mcm
within update id subject to some
condition that i'll explain
shortly then we can
use this algorithm as a black box and
transform it into a different algorithm
a prime
which maintains a
beta times one plus epsilon approximate
mcm
a very different matching possibly but
with a similar approximation guarantee
and within a similar update time of t
plus
some constant over epsilon
and this new algorithm also has a
worst case recourse bound of some
constant over epsilon
okay so the transformed algorithm a
prime
enjoys the same guarantees on the
approximation
factor and update time
is a almost the same not exactly the
same
but it also achieves a worse case for
course bound
of roughly one over epsilon
and and the condition that i omitted is
that
this black box algorithm a needs to be
able to output
efficiently the edges in the matching
that it maintains within time
linear in its size
now this condition may seem very
restrictive but in fact
i'm not aware of any dynamic matching
algorithm
that doesn't meet this condition
it doesn't satisfy this condition so i'm
not sure how
restrictive this condition is but i
should mention that
if we don't have this condition so that
we don't have this linear time
guarantee then we'll have a blow up in
the update time of the transformed
algorithm which is
this this uh blow up will be
proportional
to the slack that we have here in in the
time needed to output the matching
okay
now if the original update time bound is
amortized or worst case
so is the resulting time bound t plus
roughly 1 over epsilon and in any case
the recourse bound
always holds in the worst case
now we talked about
um the setting where
edges come and go and the vertices are
fixed but
even if we consider a generalized
setting where we have
both edge and vertex updates
or just vertex updates it will still
hold
this transformation
and
this is uh an optimal bound on the
recourse bound when
we are talking about
an approximation factor of roughly one
plus epsilon
so we show that if we would like to
maintain
and approximate um
a one perception approximate mcm
you cannot get a sympathetically better
than one over epsilon
recourse bound even for incremental
or decremental settings and even in the
amortized sense
and and i should mention that if one
over epsilon is constant
then obviously it's optimal so here i
implicitly assumed
that one over epsilon is some super
constant parameter that depends
on the graph size on n
so we cannot do better than one over
epsilon
one over epsilon is the right answer for
the problem
and finally
we generalize this uh
transformation to weighted matchings
okay so now let's use another uh
arbitrary parameter w and let's assume
that
the edge weights are always contained in
this range between 1 and w
not necessarily integers
but they are in this range
and we can get
similar transformation we get
the same bound on the approximation
guarantee but the
update time will increase not by
an additive term of one over epsilon or
constant
over epsilon but rather w times
this constant over epsilon and the worst
case recourse bound will
grow from constant over epsilon to
constant times w over epsilon okay so
you see this w
everywhere we just replace one by w
and so this is what we
get
now i'm not going to give any technical
details
behind the proofs of these theorems i
chose to focus on the statements
themselves
and also on the descriptions
of the settings particularly the dynamic
setting
but i want to conclude with the
following
um first we saw that by relaxing
the parameter delta which controls the
symmetric difference size between
consecutive or adjacent configurations
is very useful it's useful for the
matching reconfiguration problem
but maybe it's also useful for other
reconfiguration problems
now the main takeaway message of this
work
is the applicability of the matching
reconfiguration problem
to dynamic matching algorithms and i
believe this
applicability deserves further study and
i'm not
necessarily talking about improving the
dependence on w
in the theorem from the previous slide
there the one on the black box
reduction for maximum weight matching
which is also
a nice question i'm talking more broadly
than that
and also maybe there is a similar
applicability for
other reconfiguration problems
and maybe in this way we could get
improvements
for other dynamic graph algorithms
outside the scope of graph matchings
finally graph reconfiguration
captures an inherent tension between
two somewhat contradictory
objectives the first is a global
objective of transforming
one global solution to another and the
second is the local objective
of carrying out this transformation
gradually
so that consecutive
configurations along the way
or adjacent configurations should be
very close one to another
okay so we have this parameter delta
that controls how close they are
it would be very interesting i believe
to study connections to other settings
that capture a similar tension beyond
dynamic graph algorithms
so one example could be to distributed
computing
another could be to property testing
also streaming algorithms
and and more and
and i'll stop here thank you
you